[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
bio stacey cabinet selection three steps
for success
i'm christy jewell of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator to today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by lab console to learn more please
visit
labconco.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also use that ask a question box
to let us know if you're having any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd now like to welcome our speaker for
today's webinar
david wiscecia director of biosafety
products at lab congo corporation
for a complete biography on david please
visit the biography tab at the top left
of your screen
welcome david you may now begin your
presentation
thanks so much christy and welcome
everyone today we're going to spend
the next several minutes talking about
how to navigate the complexities of
selecting a class 2 bio safety cabinet
many of you know this is the functional
unit of research
in a bio safety or a really a life
science laboratory
and along the way to selecting a cabinet
there are a lot of different choices
that you have to consider
everything from
is it the appropriate model for your
application to sustainability efforts
your laboratory may have
to to other requirements outside of your
own research and work directly from your
facilities
so we're going to talk about a couple of
core
things today really the first thing is
just to get a groundwork for
uh biosafety requirements depending on
the type of work you might be
handling in a biosafety cabinet in your
research and then the three areas we're
really going to focus on are
understanding the types of biosafety
cabinets and understanding which model
is most beneficial
to your work into your building
then we're also going to look at how to
plan for the future and keep in mind
things like flexibility and scientific
research and sustainability for the long
haul as many of you start to look at
ways to craft that message and that
story with how you conduct your research
in your lab
and also we're going to look at
specifics for pairing that bsc with your
workflow with unique models and features
that can promote
improved workflow on your day-to-day
laboratory work
so starting off with an understanding of
where biosafety cabinets
are used cannot be done without an
understanding of why we need to use them
in the first place
biosafety cabinets in their name are
designed to work with things that are
pathogenic or hazardous in nature and
when we think about a biohazard we're
typically referring to some kind of
agent that's infectious
and poses a risk to health whether that
be health of an animal
a plant or
in the case of the last few years of the
global pandemic human health
so when you're working with uh lots of
different things in the laboratory of
course not everything is going to be a
biohazard but you should be
very keenly aware of those
items that you might be handling that do
require additional
safety in the area of biohazard
protection
there are a lot of different organisms
out there that are infectious and so the
best way to classify those is to
understand
uh the the resources that you have
within your facility and outside of your
facility to assess those risks and
handle them properly
the best place to start is with your
safety office and that could be at a
large institution that might be your bio
safety office it may be a part of your
eh and s department
for some laboratories it could be a
single person who maybe who receives
training externally or works with a
consultancy to establish parameters that
are
ensuring that workplace safety is
promoted throughout any biohazard
application
so a lot of the directives for the the
principles of biosafety are going to
come from global standards for human
health
and
more specifically for biosafety those
are traditionally coming from biosafety
standards and manuals around the world
and the three most common uh for for
those of us in north america and much of
europe would be the cdc and its bmbl
currently in the sixth edition
there's also the canada biosafety
standard and the boot the who biosafety
manual
these are just some of many other
documents that are out there
and and these are great general
guidances but your industry or
application may require additional
safety practices and following
additional standards as well which is
why that safety office can be such a
great resource for understanding what
all might be required for your research
and your processes
within these groups there's a lot of
guidance of how to handle specific
organisms so fortunately you can open
one of these documents up and get a lot
of specifics on how to be behaved safely
in your laboratory and those are
typically
outlined
by associating a specific pathogen with
a risk group rating
if you look at risk groups they're
really assessing several different
things that as a whole assess the
biohazard risk for a microorganism and
so risk groups categorize based on
typically pathogenicity transmission
availability of preventative measures
such as vaccines for researchers who may
be working with these
or pathogenic or
hazardous
substances and also looking at if there
isn't a vaccine
maybe looking at a treatment as well
and as an analysis of everything that
happens with that organism is done it
can be bucketed typically into
risk groups that range usually from risk
group one to risk group four depending
on the document that you're adhering to
for bio safety
now
the organism is alone is is a pathogenic
uh consideration to take into account
but you also have to understand what
might be happening with that sample
or you simply just inspecting a tube
that's closed or are you pouring that a
liquid out aerosolizing
or putting it through much higher risk
procedures that could end up with
exposure to a laboratory individual
and so to classify how a risk group
should be handled there are additional
bio safety levels that really talk about
the preventative measures both for user
behaviors and also for facility design
that compromise that that
build up into
describing what are known as biosafety
levels typically these are bsl one
through four
where bsl two three and four typically
handle things that are hazardous to
human
health so where do biosafety cabinets
come into this and the answer is really
understanding that relationship between
risk groups and biosafety levels and
then assessing the proper way to handle
the particular research that you might
be conducting
through a risk assessment with your
facility you might come to the
conclusion that certain engineering
controls such as a biosafety cabinet are
required
here is one such example from the cdc's
bmbl that talks about when
working in a bsl2 environment which you
might do very routinely if you're
working with human cell lines
the statements that are made in the bmvl
talk about using primary containment
equipment such as a bsc when activities
involve aerosols or high splash
potential
and it further goes on to discuss
primary containment equipment also being
recommended anytime there's high-risk
infectious agents that are suspected to
be in a sample so
one could surmise that working with
anything that is pathogenic has a
pathogenic characteristic or is uh is
significant and relevant to human health
could be handled in a biosafety cabinet
and really should be
does not mean that things that are less
pathogenic or not pathogenic at all
cannot be handled in a class 2 bsc but
there are be aware that there are
minimum recommendations depending on the
risk group for your
organism now a biosafety cabinet is a
unique type of enclosure in a laboratory
and it's important to really understand
the differences between a biosafety
cabinet and all other enclosures that
are found in laboratories
across the hundreds of manufacturers of
types of enclosures for laboratories and
industrial environments
there are lots of different types of
formats for hoods some that keep you
safe some that keep your work safe
and some that keep your work and your
your users safe at the same time but
looking at the hood does not always tell
you the whole story so it's really
important for you to understand if
you're buying a new hood what is the
type of hood that you're buying is it a
fume hood or otherwise and what's that
level of protection that it's offering
with a biosafety cabinet these are
enclosures that are designed
specifically for for biological aerosols
and
less so for chemical fumes
but
there and obviously they're quite a bit
different than the fume hood which is
designed specifically for chemical fumes
and vapors
we'll go on and understand the
differences between these two a little
bit further but understanding that this
risk is really a critical component
because
you as the user or the lab manager or
the facilities person
may go and turn on a hood but air is
invisible and it's really difficult to
understand
what exactly is happening with that
hood's performance without smoke
visualization
so a bio safety cabinet
this is designed for biohazardous
aerosols
and you often see this type of hood in
applications such as those that are on
screen
so
oftentimes one of the most common uses
in academic settings would be for cell
and tissue culture
you also see these routinely in
microbiology and pathology
settings so analyzing human health
samples or maybe food microbiology
then also looking for clinical
diagnostics applications such as cova
diagnosis
or furthermore looking at
much more
high importance sterility applications
like producing cell and gene therapies
where we're growing and modulating cells
for human injection or even preparing
chemotherapies and other iv drugs that
are sterile and must be injected
directly to humans
so continuing on
it's critical to understand how a class
2 bsc works
the only true way to understand
exactly how airflows are a product like
a biosafety cabinet is to visualize with
smoke
so if you take a look at the the inlet
grille of the biosafety cabinet you can
see there's air being pulled into that
top image and that represents inflow air
that is pulling and containing hazards
in the room and pulling it underneath
the work surface so that that force of
air protects the user but it also
prevents contaminated room air from
entering that sterile working area
once the biosafety cabinet distributes
that air up through its internal
components it's going to push that air
downward and that's offering
product protection which is
a clean environment that's hepa filtered
and is
aseptic in nature
you'll notice as the smoke moves down
over that work area it's flowing very
smoothly and calmly and we often refer
to that as laminar or more appropriately
unidirectional airflow
this flow of air really works to ensure
that
the the working area is non-turbulent
and samples can get bathed in clean air
without any disruption or contamination
from sample to sample or from inside the
cabinet to outside or vice versa
so in summation a class 2 vsc is
providing personnel protection that's
user protection with an air barrier at
the front of the cabinet it's also
providing product protection which is
sterile hepa filtered laminar downflow
air
and it's also providing protection from
the environment because all of this air
is then once again being filtered
through hepa filters before returning to
the room environment
so continuing on
much of the biosafety cabinet cannot be
seen from the outside
for a user and that's an important thing
because the biosafety cabinet is
inherently a containment vessel
to get a better understanding of how
this cabinet works
you have to be aware that there are some
things that are going on with airflow
that's distributed through the back of
the cabinet and then up and filtered
through hepa filters before it returns
into the work area so this slide just
simply
summates the the flow of air from the
room into the the the back channel
behind uh all of the working areas and
then it's on its way through filtration
through hepa filters back into the work
area
should also be noted at this time
be very mindful of how your biosafety
cabinet is connected to either back into
the room or to the exhaust system for a
building when a biosafety cabinet is
recirculating its air back into the room
it is not okay to work with chemical
vapors because those vapors will pass
directly through a hepa filter
understanding how your biosafety cabinet
is going to operate is really the first
step in understanding
how you can work with it safely
but understand that before you get to
the biosafety cabinet there are
typically lots of factors that are in
play to make sure that the product is
designed to be safe and supportive of
your work whether it's very low risk or
very high risk
most manufacturers who are building
quality bses are going to design them to
a global standard
the most well-known standard in the
world is nsf ansi standard 49.
this is a globally recognized document
that changes every year and adapts to
new technologies to make sure that that
manufacturers are adhering to the
highest most stringent requirements for
universal biosafety containment
it also defines how biosafety cabinets
should be constructed and also talks
about different formats of bscs which we
will address in the next several slides
there are other standards out there as
well
many of them have their roots in nsf-49
nsf-49 is truly the most up-to-date
version that constantly receives
attention
i also want to point out that like many
standards there are grounds for the
basis of the cabinet's design but there
are many features that influence
additional behaviors about your cabinet
that promotes safer safer work and a
better understanding for users of how
they're interfacing with the cabinet on
a day-to-day basis
so diving right into biosafety cabinet
structure there are several subtypes to
be aware of the most common
design of a biosafety cabinet is a class
2 type a2 model and this is a
recirculating design that pulls air from
the room filters it and pushes it back
to the room after the air is passed
through the entire cabinet
this design is really common for
microbiology and other types of work
that involve regular bio you know
pathogenic materials but not for
chemicals
because the air is recirculated back to
the room
if chemicals are used and we're talking
more than just ethanol or a disinfectant
at the end of the day or prior to work
if more chemicals are used such as odors
or light duty chemicals an a2 can be
configured with an exhaust connection on
the top of the unit
these designs of a2 cabinets have a
partial recirculation to them
and that means that they are really for
design for work with smaller volumes of
chemicals
and and the idea there is to prevent
concentration of chemicals in the work
area that may eventually lead to an
explosive limit
so a2 cabinets are great for that small
quick procedure with chemicals but
really they're they're almost best for
applications that are microbiology
biohazardous but include unpleasant
odors such as potentially handling fecal
cell samples
so you'll notice again that purple area
now we've gone from blue to purple
purple signifies an area where it's okay
to work with some chemicals but be
mindful of your usage
and here again is just a bigger
demonstration of that area where
anywhere in the work area is safe for
minute volumes of chemicals but be
mindful of recirculation
so when you hear about type a2 bses
again they're very common
and many laboratories employ them for
routine cell culture and other similar
work
there are lots of pros to a type a
cabinet
they're very great you know
many biological applications work for
class 2 a2 bscs
they can also be used for small volumes
of chemicals and they're relatively easy
to exhaust with billing systems
they're they're also while they do cost
some amount of money as you're venting
air out of the building they're quite a
bit cheaper to run and much less complex
than a type b2 cabinet
do be aware if you have an a2 that you
are restricted to small volumes of
chemicals and this design
also can never really be you know
connected and converted into a model
that provides an even higher level of
chemical safety
so there are other bscs for work that
may involve solvents or higher volumes
of chemicals
and they came into lights
about 40 or so years ago
this is a family of of class 2 bses
called type b2 cabinets
and they are
really designed for work that involves
excess volumes of hazardous chemicals
b2 cabinets and b1 cabinets the two
cabinets that are in the bee family
are both quite temperamental and how
they run and oftentimes it requires lots
of extra planning
on the mechanical construction side of
the hood
so the ductwork and the venting and the
exhaust blower to make sure that all
goes well
the first type of bsc that is in the
type b family is the b1
and this is a cabinet that is very
difficult to use for operators to ensure
safety
you'll notice in the front of the
cabinet there's a blue area where it's
okay to work with recirculating
applications and no chemicals
in the back area there's a red area that
denotes an area where it's safe to work
with
hazardous chemistry that needs to be
vented to the outside without
recirculation
and then you'll notice a purple area
again in the middle
and this defines an area where air is
recirculating
in the front exhausted in the back and
that purple line is a smoke split line
in the cabinet
this user this line is invisible to
users so
often times when you see a b1 cabinet
there's information that's supplied with
the man from the manufacturer of that
cabinet that says extreme user training
for b1 has to be considered
otherwise a user may end up working with
chemicals in the front of the cabinet
and become
create an unsafe condition
bu1 cabinets also have to be dedicated
to one exhaust duct run and one blower
per biosafety cabinet which means you
cannot connect these easily
or safely to a shared exhaust system
such as with other fume hoods in a
building
furthermore if the exhaust system does
not behave correctly the b cabinet
itself has to recognize an issue with
that cabinet or with the exhaust system
and then shut down within 15 seconds
leaving the air dead and a user with an
unsafe condition including hazardous
microbiology coming out of the cabinet
potentially
b2 cabinets were another development
that turned
a class to b
into a total exhaust
biosafety cabinet so if you look at this
design you'll notice the entire work
area is red and that means that it's
safe to work with hazardous chemicals in
addition to microbiological samples at
any time in any area of the b2 cabinet
however there are restrictions that come
with these cabinets
the one uh big big limiting factor is
again
this design has to be connected to the
exhaust duct run
facility infrastructure at all times
it also exhausts a substantial amount of
air because the entire work area is 100
vented to the outside
and in doing all of this you still have
the same restriction where if the
cabinet does not have sufficient exhaust
it must shut down
very fast and prevent an issue where the
cabinet
[Music]
would potentially push
hazards into the room so it is a is a
risky situation to have a b2
that does not have a sufficient exhaust
blower or a stable exhaust blower
so many times
you may see text or language or
questions that say b2s are a safe
biosafety cabinet
and this slide will really the focus
here is to address when that statement
is true
so for type b2 cabinets for biohazards
they actually type b2 cabinets offer no
additional safety versus a type a or a
type c cabinet that's because the
benchmark for assessing bio safety and
biocontainment for a class ii bsc is
developed and tested to a certain
standard that the bsc was made and
constructed and tested to so in the case
of nsf-49 the bio-containment principles
and requirements for a class 2 bsc do
not change from type to type
in the case of chemicals a b2 cabinet
can offer additional safety over
an a cabinet or another cabinet but
the the instances there must require
that the cabinet is running properly
b2 cabinets and b1 cabinets rely
entirely on the building for their
exhaust
and the building is a separate system
from the the cabinet itself which means
that getting these two to marry and work
properly can be very difficult and even
after it works properly it may the
conditions may change due to
fluctuations in temperature from the
building to the outside
or other conditions where
maybe a b2 may be shared with other
exhaust ductwork such as a fume hood
so in summary looking at bees the pros
for them is they do provide exhaust and
dedicated chemical safety for a type b2
cabinet
but there are lots of cons and that
includes the dedicated duct run
bees always must be vented so you're
always wasting expensive air by dumping
that straight out of your building
they also have that limitation where
they have to shut down very quickly in
the event of an exhaust failure in a
building
it does happen and if there's no
redundancy or additional power supply
for that blower it can create an
extremely dangerous situation
furthermore
looking at the volume of air that's
displaced out of the building by a b2 is
it you have to look at how it compares
to an a2 that may be vented and b2s use
about twice as much energy as an a2 that
is canopy vented which means they are
twice as costly to run for every bit of
research and work that's done in the
cabinet
lastly there's no flexibility with type
b2 cabinets so
imagine you select a type b2 cabinet
because you're doing some chemical work
and then six months later you've changed
your processes or perhaps the researcher
that was doing that work has left your
facility and you picked up a different
project
well maybe you don't need to vent the
cabinet anymore
but with a type b cabinet you are always
committed to that exhaust
out of the building whether you're
working with a simple e coli sample or a
large volume chemical buffer inside of a
biosafety cabinet
to help understand
the mechanical complexities of a
building here's a quick diagram just to
give you a picture of
a facility that has a clean room and
several bio safety cabinets
um in this condition there are actually
although it's called out of five there
are a total of six bscs on this drawing
and they are sharing ductwork all
together to make use of a single blower
and that's really great when you have a
a non-b2 cabinet or a non-be cabinet
because you can gang other types of
biosafety cabinets such as type a and
type c
unfortunately with type b's when they're
ganged together like this they're very
sensitive and have lots of
support of consistent
stability with their airflow and
sometimes it's very difficult to get
them to work properly which means in
turn that a user may be post put in risk
if the exhaust system does not balance
all cabinets appropriately
so there are several documents and
statements talking about doing
anything but this kind of design with
type b cabinets but unfortunately many
times mechanical planners for buildings
do not have the considerations for b
cabinets in mind they haven't done their
homework with the the manuals and the
requirements for the industry
and pose risk to users and and even just
to get the bsc up and running can be a
challenge
so there are other options um you can
use a type a2 but that has restrictions
with chemical safety
and so there is another type of bsc that
may be selected for these types of labs
that either have flexibility concerns
you know what's going to happen five to
15 years down the road
or they're just really focused on energy
reduction and savings without
really losing any safety at all and so
the type c one is is that that bsc that
can help with all of those concerns
about a's versus b's or really just
future proofing your cabinet for for the
remainder of its life
the type c ones are flexible in the
sense that they can work in either a
recirculating mode or b exhausted mode
and when they're in that b mode when you
decide to invent the cabinet you would
simply certify the bfc and connect it to
exhaust ducts and in that b mode you
have an 100 dedicated vent area from the
central part of the work surface which
is well defined
and easy to follow as a worker
when ducted
there are also much easier connection
points for the c1 to the building so it
has smaller exhaust volume to save that
energy and cost
of conditioning and it also has much
lower exhaust
static pressure or suction requirements
of the cabinet
and
additionally it this type of cabinet can
be connected with many other bfcs and
fume hoods on the same shared ductwork
so it's much easier to incorporate
whether you are planning for a new large
building or you're planning for
renovating an existing building that has
a whole set of duct infrastructure
already
implemented
as i mentioned there's flexibility and
that means that you can go back and
forth from a to b mode with a simple
certification and connecting the cabinet
to ductwork or just or removing it from
ductwork so every six months or a year
or so when that certification happens is
a great time for this bsc to change its
course and save your laboratory crucial
exhaust air
the work surface is designed in such a
way that there is segments to help
understand where it's safe to work
there are also nsf approved flat work
surfaces for the entire work area to be
flush if you want to use this in just a
recirculating mode
and
additionally in that vented mode in that
b mode this cabinet also has other
features that keep users safe when
building conditions may not be stable
and this cabinet actually has the
ability to run for an additional five
minutes to keep the bio hazards within
the cabinet and to protect a user from
loss of containment due to building
failure
the type c1 bses look like this image
here and they have that dedicated
central area to work in
which really promotes the area where you
handle your samples in active state
so it really promotes aseptic workflow
with your consumables on the left
your work in the middle and you're
discarding on the right and it keeps
that left to right or right to left flow
depending on your preference for aseptic
work
looking at sustainability is a really
critical part of any decision for
today's modern laboratories you you want
to be conscious of those those factors
that really eat excess energy and
laboratories are one of the most um
energy consuming uh locations uh out
there and and to do a little bit uh on
retaining some of that energy savings
can go a long ways not only into the
messaging for your laboratory and it's
it's commitment to green development
but also it means direct savings for
your facility
a great way to look at this is the
energy consumption by the exhaust air
from a bio cabinet
so there's energy consumption just for
running a bio safety cabinet but looking
at
the exhaust air alone you can see some
pretty significant values associated
with running bscs so recirculating
cabinets are just taking room air and
recirculating within the room so there's
zero cost
with a canopy to a2 you're exhausting
about four
uh forty to forty five thousand dollars
over fifteen years of the cabinet's life
so that's a pretty substantial cost
with a b2 that's providing the same
level of bio protection with just a
little bit of added chemical protection
that number more than doubles and as you
can imagine a hundred thousand dollars
over the course of 15 years
is almost the cost of a new b2 bsc
every year so it's very expensive to run
a c1 gets you that same protection
factor as a b2 but at a much lower cost
so it pays for itself very quickly if
you're going to know that you're going
to be doing chemical style work
and it also promotes additional safety
factors that a b does not allow
so to summarize these types you have the
type a2 which is very common for routine
microbiology and cell culture work that
does not
involve hazardous chemicals
it can be vented to the outside with a
canopy or symbol connection for light
duty applications involving chemicals or
odors
cabinets are 100 exhaust for higher
volumes of chemicals but have lots of
limitations that impact both expensive
installations and operating costs and
also safety risk to users
the type c1 bridges that gap by offering
a type a2 or type b2 style environment
within the cabinet allows you to switch
between the two as your needs flex and
change and also allows for really easy
installation
reduced cost for operating and provides
additional safety that's not found in an
a2 or a b2 cabinet
as you consider all of these factors you
also want to be mindful of that
sustainability message that happens
outside of the individual type of bsc
but for all types of bscs and so some of
the things you should really be paying
attention there are are really the
opportunities to reduce total
consumption by the product and also
consumption by the upkeep and ongoing
maintenance for a bio safety cabinet
many times
facilities who are looking for lead
credits or are looking at sustainability
metrics are going to look towards the
energy consumption for a device
one of the most power hungry devices in
a laboratory
based on energy consumption at the
device itself is a ultra low temperature
freezer such as a minus 80.
biosafety cabinets in
comparison use a significantly less
amount of energy to to you uh to operate
the internal blowers that they they work
off of
and you can easily contact any reputable
manufacturer to understand the watts and
the consumption for a bsc
in looking at a type a2 recirculating
cabinet these are our enclosures that
use about 50
or so in the us per year to operate in
recirculating fashion so they're they're
quite energy efficient today for many
models
as you look at that though you need to
also consider is the cabinet being
exhausted and does my application really
really warrant exhausting of the process
many times there's a misconception that
exhausting a process of just
microbiology microbiological samples
makes the process safer when in reality
you become
reliant partially or fully on that
exhaust system to provide safety and in
doing so
actually transfers some of the
responsibility of safety away from an
intelligent bsc and into a totally
separate system in the exhaust
so not only is it less safe but you're
also spending energy so evaluating
whether or not you need to exhaust a
hood is a really critical step into
sustainability and safety and that's
where that type c1 can make a big
difference in allowing you to flex and
change as your applications change
i think the other piece that's really
critical is to pay attention to
the energy as an important factor a
benchmark for how the product is
designed
but really to understand all of the
other factors that influence how much
money is added into the the ownership of
the bsc from maintenance and so the area
to look at there is keenly focused on
avoiding landfill and
secondary and tertiary
disruptors to sustainability
one of the big things there is to look
at construction quality and the
longevity of a biosafety cabinet they
really today a bfc should be designed to
last no less than 15 years without any
major service besides filters
filters are internal to the cabinet and
are the routine maintenance device
component for a bio cabinet when we talk
about routine we're talking in the order
of close to 10 years or more for
blowers that are supporting opera
airflow through a cabinet
many cabinets do not have extra reserve
capacity to withstand filter loading
and when you do not have that
your your energy costs may look low
because the blowers are using less
energy but
your end up your total costs are quite
high because you're spending perhaps a
thousand us dollars
or more for filter change you have
someone who's driving to your facility
polluting the environment throwing away
filters all just so you can save a
little bit of energy cost up front and
so the total perspective of a cabinet
over its life is critical to investigate
lastly you also want to be mindful of
how the cabinet is constructed and work
with a reputable manufacturer who's
sourcing recycled content that's the
steel and other components that go into
the hood and making sure that they stay
in such a state that they can be
recycled at the end of the product's
life
many times biosafety cabinets are being
carefully deconstructed and
decontaminated at the end of their life
now and recycled as much as possible
which really reduces that landfill
characteristic
so the last piece i want to talk about
is identifying not only the right style
or type of bsc but also focusing on on
what modifications and customizations
are are available to you to make your
work safer
and easier and more friendly when you're
spending long time periods of time in
the biosafety cabinet
so
at the core of a bsc structure is that
compliance to nsf or en or other global
standards
and adhering to that design is critical
because it ensures the product is going
to perform real safe
and be you know reputable design
but there are things that are out there
that influence and improve the way some
of your work gets done
but be mindful of those additional
modifications and things that can be
selected to ensure you're selecting a
biostation tablet that fits your work
and allows you to do it as safely as
possible
so some of those modifications uh i've
got in these next few slides one of
those big ones is micro microscope
integrations and adaptations
you'll notice in this image here we have
uh two different ways to integrate
microscopes on the left there's an
inverted microscope sitting there with
eyepieces passing through the lens
and then the the lenses are coming
through the uh the glass sash of the bsc
this design allows for a user to work
safely with cell culture flasks that may
be open and biohazardous or
maybe working with dissection
microscopes to to view a stereoscope and
get closer work to something that's
pathogenic or biohazardous while still
maintaining proper airflow and
containment within a bsc
on the right is another option that
involves integrating a larger
microscope design into the work surface
and that promotes a better
air flows through the cabinet and also
ergonomics for a user to work smoothly
across the biosafety cabinet design so
these are options out there for
microscopy and cabinets
there's also additional micro uh
integrations that can go on beyond
microscope integration and
as many of you are starting to work with
additional devices and designs and
cabinets you may be aware of larger
instruments that need to go into bscs
that are doing critical steps and
functions in the biosafety cabinet for
instance here is an automated bioreactor
and it is connected through lots of
different
passers and cords to support all the
complexities of the cabinet
and the uh and the bioreactor itself
while still allowing for good airflow
and
the ergonomics are still maintained for
a user
some of you may also be working with
samples that are for human health
and are going to be injected so cell
therapies or gene therapies or other
sterile products that are processed
in accordance with the gmps
in doing so you may have additional
requirements for monitoring
in this case there is an isokinetic
probe for air sampling that collects air
from the work area and helps validate
the sterility of your product
in this design
a funnel can be added and integrated
into the biosafety cabinet rather than
running extra lines through the whole
work area which can be difficult to
clean
many of your processes may also include
digital laboratory notebooks or other
processes that are best displayed
on screens associated with the biosafety
cabinet either integrated into the back
wall or connected through a laptop arm
or a monitor arm and these are things
that you should work with closely with
your manufacturer because they really
influence
how little space you have in your
laboratory and how best you can maximize
the area that the bsc is taking up by
integrating
monitors and getting rid of things like
computer cards
those of you who are working with
instruments that are also quite a bit
larger
may also find that your bsc
is not big enough even if you do some
basic modifications to it and so on the
left we have
one such liquid handler that fits well
into a biosafety cabinet
but a liquid handler such as the
hamilton star may be too large for a
standard bsc and in fact this model
particularly the hamilton star is too
large for a regular bfc
so be aware of other conform
conforming products that help maintain
class 2 airflows and support automation
as well and so some of the formats that
are out there are are wide and diverse
and highly customized and expensive but
there are options that are very very
compatible with many different types of
liquid handlers cell sorters and other
instruments that are too large for
regular bsc
so these large enclosures are available
in
different formats but what you really
want to focus in on is understanding the
space requirements for instrument and
then working with a manufacturer who's
got a lot of experience closely
designing these products
testing them with instruments inside of
them and making sure that all of that is
maintaining class 2 protection for
personnel that's you the user for the
product that's hand being handled inside
the enclosure and at the same time
maintaining ergonomics safety and
comfort
so these are just a few of the selection
options that you have to consider both
with the type of the bsc
the the sustainability considerations
and cost savings for your facility
as they pertain to both uh operational
costs and safety costs and then also
being mindful of other ways to select
bscs that can be adapted to improve your
workflows and make your day easier in
the laboratory or wherever you might be
using a class 2 bsc and so with that i'm
going to turn it over to
questions that have come in during the
presentation and thanks again for
joining
thank you david for that informative
presentation it is now time to start our
live q a portion of the webinar down to
our audience if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now just
use that ask a question box type it in
there click submit and we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
okay david let's get started we have
lots of questions that have come in here
uh let's start with this one
why would i want to use a type c in
center type d
good question um so a type c cabinet is
going to be that cabinet that can work
for any type of application whether it's
covet samples or
it's ebola samples
all are suitable on the biological side
the difference really with the c is
is on the chemistry and chemical vapor
handling side
a c is going to be a lot easier to
integrate into a building it's got
flexibility in terms of
how much air it exhausts
how safe it is that are leaps and bounds
ahead of a type b cabinet so it's
providing the same level of protection
by having 100 exhausted air without a
lot of the hang-ups and hiccups that
type b2 cabinets can sometimes bring to
the party
thanks david
next question we work with tuberculosis
samples is an a2 okay for this type of
work
so
uh as a biosafety cabinet manufacturer
our our recommendation is always going
to be for you to consult most closely
with your biosafety officer or your ehs
office and understand the the facility
requirements and the local requirements
for handling any biohazard
now for something like tuberculosis this
is obviously a highly infectious
pathogenic
organism that we really don't want to
have anything to do with and we want to
make sure we handle it safely so
a biohazard
such as this
is not a chemical risk by itself and so
we want to make sure that we look at
does a cabinet have the ability to
contain and all class ubscs are going to
provide that same level of
biocontainment so an a2 is acceptable
you may just be aware of in especially
because we have lots of international
guests
your country may have specific
requirements for handling tuberculosis
in a vented
enclosure but there is no known benefits
to exhausting a bsc
for handling tuberculosis so
samples the common misconception
thanks for that answer david next
question we just bought a new liquid
handler can we still get a bio safety
cabinet for it
this is also a great question um
so thank you for asking
when you're
buying a liquid handler i have been in
this case before where you're very
excited about how fast it's going to
make your work and it's going to
automate your process so you can you
know go work on other more important
things than transferring liquids from
from a sample
through the different phases of a
process
it also means that you may have
forgotten to look at the bsc
and sounds like in this case this user
has done that
the answer is is really you want to look
closely at the liquid handler you have
collect all of the information about the
model and then go to a manufacturer of a
larger enclosure and understand
what types of options they have for for
containing that liquid handler so in the
case of um large enclosures such as the
ones that lab conco makes there are lots
of different options uh for for
different sizes and connections and
customizations that can support adapting
an enclosure to the liquid handler you
may have already bought
having said that do be aware that some
instruments do require very large or
sometimes even completely customized in
containment so most liquid handlers
that's not the case but if you have a
large robotics process with multiple
steps
may require additional conversation
right david we're going to try squeezing
in a few more questions we have quite a
few coming in
i do want to let our audience know that
any of the questions we are unable to
get to we will be answering them via
email to the
email address that you provided at the
time of registration all right david
what is the difference between a vented
and non-vented filter bsc for coded
testing
that's a good question um yeah so
so coveted testing by itself is
uh for testing of a pathogenic human
sample a clinical sample requires in the
us just a bfl2 containment and that
means to traditionally you're working
with that sample if it's still
pathogenic in a class 2 bse it could be
any one of the the types of class 2bses
that are out there so it could be
recirculating or vented to the outside
phobid is is a viral particulate right
so
it's a virus in nature so
as you're handling it the hepa filters
with the bsc are going to be entirely
responsible for capturing that that
zykovic sample the virus
and so there's really not a benefit at
all or even a requirement to venting a
class ubsc for working with covet
testing
the only situation where you may choose
to vent a copic processing bsc is if for
some reason you were also working with
additional chemicals or
or something smelly like a different
sample besides the covid sample maybe
maybe a fecal sample or you want to vent
the other route but inherently there is
no real requirement
with a bsc to vent it out for covid
david what cabinet do you recommend for
animal work
good question um so there are lots of
different types of enclosures for uh
safe bio hazardous
animal handling um many times if you
look at the offerings um that are out
there there are it depends on the
process that is occurring so it may be
that you are exchanging an animal from
cage to cage such as a mouse and there
are great transfer stations that are
designed for that type of work that
provides both user and sample protection
or animal protection
if you're working with surgeries or
doing a thing a little bit more critical
with that animal
then typically there are class two bio
safety cabinets that are specialty
designs for working with animals
the key design concept there is is
usually a larger sash opening to allow
for passing of smaller cages in and out
of the work area such as a 12-inch sash
opening
all right and it looks like we have time
for one more question
are class 2 b2 cabinets louder than
others i'm looking for a quiet cabinet
does that exist
that's like that's a great question um
so
i mentioned earlier that class two bscs
are driven by
uh a building exhaust blower so
internally in a b2 cabinet there is just
a smaller blower typically uh for
supplying air down over the work area
the remaining air is sucked out from the
building itself
and as that happens there is a
substantial volume
of air that is pulled through a b2
cabinet it's quite quite loud because
it's double the air of a type a2 or a
type c1 cabinet so
if you look at the manufacturer's specs
for all b2 cabinets they typically say
they're pretty quiet but that is because
they're measuring the volume the noise
intensity for the cabinet and rarely the
whole picture where they're looking at
the total exhaust volume so
really b2 cabins should be avoided for
many reasons
and
one of those extra extra reasons down
the road is that volume
um and you know temperamentalness that
they also bring with them
david thank you so much for all of this
information do you have any final
comments for our audience
i wanted to just again thank you all for
your time and your fantastic questions i
know there are lots of other questions
that did not get answered just during
our short time today and we will address
those directly afterwards for those of
you who have questions
if you have more information on bscs
that you're requesting or want
additional help
feel free to visit labconco.com and get
in touch with one of our several
specialists for biosafety cabinets
otherwise thanks so much again for
attending and have a great rest of your
day
thank you again david and just a
reminder to our audience today's webcast
can be viewed on demand and lab roots
will alert you via email when it is
available to replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event a
big thank you again to david lazecha and
labconco and we hope you all have a
great day
you